well brian and denise this is not the
outcome
anyone wanted to see in this case metro
police say two-year-old amari nicholson
was killed
and the suspect is his mother's
boyfriend who is now behind bars
and it's still unclear if police have
found the boy's body
this case started out as a missing
person's investigation
and unfortunately i'm here to tell you
today that is now a homicide
a tragic turn in the nearly week long
search for two-year-old damari nicholson
sources tell the i-team amari's mother's
boyfriend 27-year-old terrell rhodes
confessed to murdering the toddler
rhodes was transported to the clark
county detention center metro police
arresting rhodes tuesday
amore was first reported missing on may
5th last seen at the emerald suites at
paradise and twain
for days the community set up several
search parties
to try and find him police saying the
circumstances surrounding this case
were suspicious as the investigation
progressed
it became very clear to us that terrell
rhodes
was our primary suspect rhodes spoke to
eight news now last week claiming a
woman took omaree from the emerald
suites where they were staying while the
mother was in colorado
they notified herself as
my girlfriend baby daddy's sister
and they said they were sure to pick up
more and
notified me that it was already
pre-arranged amari's father's side of
the family denying that ever happened
despite the holsen road story
amari's mother stood by what he said
rhodes even responding to those who
suspected him
what's really sickening is that people
is
making assumptions thinking that i had
something to do with it
we had never done nothing like that to
him metro also says during rhodes arrest
he fought with police officers
and took an officer's gun now he faces
additional charges to his felony murder
charge
rhodes has been booked into the clark
county detention center and records show
his first court appearance is scheduled
for tomorrow morning
meanwhile police are continuing to ask
anyone with any information
about this case to call crime stoppers
where they can remain anonymous
reporting live from metro headquarters
tonight orcomanna 8 news now